[Music]
there were once two sisters
the older sister walked ahead of the
younger one
so the younger one always knew where to
go
how are you doing because your graham
and i have been a little worried about
you my sister is dead
there's no more music in me
no more dreams in me
i've lost the one person on earth who
understood me
how's school bad as expected
he's a new boy in honor band
[Music]
hey
you must be lennon walker
toby stop by go keep him company make
him feel welcome he is not interested in
talking to me
she was the love of his life
no one in school gets it
i don't think it's possible to get it
unless you're in it like we are um
you believe in science from the beyond i
believe in everything cause you've got
me yes
by the way
the heart breaks
music escapes
that's how it gets out
if the tide takes california
[Music]
i'm so glad i got joe fontaine
toby shaw
i know i shouldn't have come i just
missed her so much
we're here
without her
[Music]
okay
we're gonna be okay
[Music]
i don't think cricket one was out
together
with joe i feel so very alive
but when i'm with toby there is someone
with me in my grief
i want to live like my sister did
with daring
[Music]
and so
much joy
[Music]
you